sometimes I don't even watch the things
I've been in I do watch it to be
practical to see what I can do better or
you know just to see if I if I'm having
the right effect on the audience
I don't ever watch myself like a fan and
say yes you were awesome in that scene
buddy bodyshop the character robbed an
American body shop was my first leading
role on a TV show it was a pretty
inconsequential show on Comedy Central
but it was an exciting big deal for me I
had auditioned for so many series and
and you know come very close to like
getting them and never got them
[Music]
rob was easily the best part on the show
it was sort of mockumentary was pretty
broadly comic I just remember I had an
unexplained bald spot but I was really
excited about good news another under
carriage road test we came up with it
when we were like cooking up our looks
all the other guys were did the like
normal frat guy thing where they were
like oh I should I should roll up my
sleeves and have like cool hair like
Danny Zuko and I was like I want to have
a weird bald spot and always have some
mad scientist glasses and like a weird
handlebar mustache and be filthy
Children's Hospital I did a movie with
Rob Corddry in the early 2000s I guess
and we had a blast
he was the white mayor of this town and
I was his sheriff and we had a lot of
fun and we kind of hit it off and then
shortly after that he wrote Children's
Hospital and he sent it to me and I
loved it and I thought it was so funny
and he also said they had the idea to
cast my wife Megan Mullally in the role
of chief and we both just thought it was
the funniest thing we had seen and were
desperate to do it Megan got to do it I
unfortunately got sidelined with this
other show called Parks and Recreation
which totally ruined my Children's
Hospital career so I was supposed to be
a regular on Children's Hospital in the
role of chance Briggs but after some
negotiation NBC agreed to let me do like
one or two per season so I got to still
do a handful of them the reason so many
funny people were on that show is
because it was so fun to work on it was
completely filthy and irreverent there
were no rules you were required to be as
stupid as possible hey when's the last
time you had your prostate checked I
don't have time for that kind of thing
um do you have time for cancer get in
here no you get in here we loved working
it was really fun it felt like we were
getting away with something
Parks and Recreation parks and
recreation is that the one with
star-lord I was a big fan of the office
I originally auditioned for the role of
Michael Scott Dave Koechner who played
Todd Packer among other you know
legendary comedy roles he and I
auditioned the same day to play Michael
Scott so I was a huge fan of the office
and I had known Rainn Wilson for a long
time and I would say to Meghan we'd
watch the office and I would say you
know what if I'm ever gonna get like a
big break I think it's gonna be on a
show like this in a part like Dwight
root which is crazily exactly what
happened but they were creating Parks
and Rec and they had me in to read for a
different part who was a romantic
interest for a Rashida's character and
it went great
and and everybody was very happy and
they sent the tape to NBC and they said
literally he's a quote Nick Offerman you
said someone like Aaron Eckhart and he
sent us this hog believe that was the
term they used so NBC said no to me as a
love interest for rashida
but then Mike Schur and Greg Daniels the
creators said shoot we really like this
guy and we want him on the show let's
make him that part of Amy's boss that
should be 20 years older than he is and
they called me and said they wanted me
to do that and NBC then made me audition
for like five months they looked at
every other person in the world who
could speak English but Mike and Greg
stuck to their guns and finally gave me
the part it was a libertarian who hated
the government and that was the impetus
of the of the role and you know then
together we added layers on to him
they made him a woodworker because I
like runs woodshop on the show is my
actual shop in real life and his canoes
like I made those canoes and stuff like
that so you know I think with any
character on a show that lasts
it's a collaboration between the writers
and the actor to continue fleshing it
out coloring in between the lines as you
go you have two choices
one get rid of Tammy or two lobotomy and
castration choose wisely but this is a
waste of time the mustache was one of
the looks that I had had on stage like I
definitely favored a substantial
mustache that was the first thing we
agreed upon was that he would have a
kick-ass mustache the hairdo was sort of
developed over the first season but we
called it the full douche we thought it
was really funny and other than that the
Mike Schur and Greg Daniels said to me
to the whole cast we want you guys to
feel real so if the show gets picked up
please don't start doing Pilates and
lose a bunch of weight and he
specifically asked me to state beefy so
I ate at least two cheeseburgers a day
for seven years the rest as they say is
history
all good things people were crazy about
the documentary of the jinx with good
reason the man who made it Andrew
Jarecki before he made the jinx made a
narrative feature of the same God story
starring Ryan Gosling as Robert Durst
Kirsten Dunst as his wife and murder
victim allegedly and I was cast as her
brother these are all real-life people
and it was really good I mean there's a
really good movie Andrew Jarecki had put
together an incredible packet of
research so there was video there was
interviews I believe they asked me if I
wanted to go meet the guy and I didn't
want to I was freaked out I think
Christian Bale would be ashamed of me
Kirsten and I saw screening of it in LA
when it was done it was so good and then
at the end
Robert Durst is still living in like
Galveston selling real estate the movie
made you so furious because this guy
clearly was a killer and he was walking
free we walked out of the screening and
we were like this movie sucks like I
hate this movie because it doesn't end
like that story we know that story like
oh then he went to jail I was like no
this guy's still you can go see him and
we were really angry so I was really
happy that Andrew I mean what tenacity
he's stuck with the story and made the
jinx won a bunch of trophies and got
Robert Durst to confess I'm scream acts
come a good friend of mine named Martin
garner who was a guy who we've done some
writing partnering we had written some
stuff together and he found the graphic
novel of axe cop and brought it to my
attention and a couple other friends did
too like I guess because he had a
mustache and he had sort of a deadpan
delivery I knew people at Fox animation
and I brought it to them and so we ended
up making a cartoon of it I just thought
it was so wickedly hilarious despite my
involvement I was surprised it wasn't a
hit it never really like took off as a
huge animated hit but the people who
loved it really loved it I mean I think
for some reason people just didn't
discover cuz it's really funny I loved
doing voiceover stuff it's a way to get
to work out really funny writing that
you know doesn't have the limits of the
physical world so you can be stupid in
so many more ways in a cartoon I always
seemed to be cast as people who scream
or somehow enter battle and so I always
end up just destroying my voice because
you're not limited you know if you're
fighting a dragon in real life you can
only do so many takes because of the
budget but an animated
work you can kill the dragon all day
long so I always tend to lose my voice
so I've had to learn to be very careful
so that I can go home and still speak to
my wife we're the Millers we're the
Millers I played on Fitzgerald and when
that came to me I just thought it was
really funny Jennifer Aniston is amazing
and Jason Sudeikis is really funny and
to be a comic duo with Kathryn Hahn
who's just like a comedy tornado was
absolutely delightful
I choose things because I think the
writing is good and I thought that was a
really funny script and seemed like a
blast
which it turned out to be that was that
was upsetting I that required a lot of
therapy on my part
afterwards I still get weird around
people's ears so I guess we're swam that
was just something I did the director
may have suggested it you know you get
in those situations and just start
playing around
I believe ear intercourse was just one
of those lucky inspirations probably the
toughest thing was trying not to laugh
at Jason Sudeikis like especially in
that tense scene he really made me crack
up I pride myself on not breaking easily
but when I do I go for it the lego movie
our business wants everybody to be a
specialist you know if your big break is
playing a tennis champion then nobody
wants to see you in a movie about
basketball so we've talked about you
know in my acting roles I've tried not
to get pigeonholed and Ron Swanson ESCA
roles but when people cast you in an
animated work they're casting your voice
and what you sound like which I'm kind
of fine with but then that I sort of
reached a limit where I was like I can't
if I was an actor I wouldn't do the this
exact same thing for every job and so
it's really grateful when Phil Lord and
Chris Miller cast me his metal beard and
in our first session we played around
with what what does this guy sound like
this weird sounding like you know like
Irish payrate robot and I was so happy
that I could do a funny voice and I
would love to do all kinds of funny
voices and I know it's going to be
really hard wiping you bum with a hook
for a hand is really hard I think we're
gonna do more lego movie stuff I suppose
it all depends on how it's doing
business-wise but the last I heard I
thought there was more to come so I'll
be happy to do metal beard until they
run out of ideas
me Earl and the dying girl that film was
great it was a wonderful book it was a
wonderful script adapted by the by the
book writer just across the board it was
a work of art it was a beautiful thing
to be a part of the cast was great we
shot it in Pittsburgh which is where it
was set and the young actors were
astonishingly good frankly they were
annoying because the competence that
they displayed at age you know 19 to
like 23 I have not yet achieved and I'll
be 50 this year
so I despised them and still do you have
not even wrapped her college drama don't
go through my stuff we discussed it and
she gets to go through your stuff
I've worked with I mean the occasional
horse or donkey I had not worked with a
cat on film and I would not recommend
anyone work with a cat on film generally
on a film set you end up having to shut
off the air conditioner because it makes
a noise so rooms get uncomfortably warm
cats don't like that and then if you
hold them and they're very hairy and
warm in general and you're creating like
furnace ball they don't like that either
and they let you know that with their
claws I was amazed that they were able
to edit together a usable footage I felt
terrible because you know that you're
being told like hold that cat against
its will so that we can photograph you
together the founder the producers have
put together an incredible Bible of
articles and interviews and there's tons
of like video interviews with with these
guys I think you have to ask the
question from the get-go am I gonna go
for like Charlize as megyn kelly in
bombshell like I'm like am I gonna go
for like total impersonation or not and
so far for me it's been not because
people don't know what the guy looks
like you know it's not Teddy Roosevelt
or something and so what we did was
glean everything we needed to about
these characters to then
fuel the story as we wanted to tell it
hey did you come up with this well I did
we did Dick MacDonald my brother working
on that film with Michael Keaton at
first that was I think the scariest
circumstance I'd been in my final scene
in the movie is is a very dramatic sort
of faceoff with him in a men's room we
shouted around at Atlanta and I'd gotten
there like a week early to get
acclimated and do costume fittings and
the director said hey we're shooting at
this Country Club
it's a scene with Michael and Laura Dern
and a couple other actors come on by and
say hi and whatever and right when I got
there they said the director said oh the
men's room here is amazing if you don't
mind I'd like to shoot your biggest
scene in the movie that you're not at
all prepared for this afternoon is that
cool and I was like yes of course Oh
well I wouldn't cool barf and so I had
to like whip it together and that's the
circumstances in which I met Michael
Keaton we showed you everything the
whole system all our secrets we were an
open book so why didn't you just steal
it just have your ideas and run out
start my own business using all those
ideas yours what a fail here's all
business not very nice you know like
don't meet your heroes and all that and
we rehearse the scene a couple times
they're like okay let us but the crew
have the set we'll get it all set up so
we have time to we go sit in two chairs
like this and then Michael Keaton is
like hey man it's like completely so
friendly and nice and what I realize is
every day he shows up and he's all
business until he gets it figured out
and then he's like alright let's talk
about baseball or fishing or whatever we
became great buddies but man working
with somebody like him you see
immediately why he's a huge movie star
he's great he's talented he's really
hard-working but he he has this met he
like shoots lightning bolts out of his
eyeballs so when you're doing a scene
with him and he turns his focus on you
at least for me I was like I have to
talk here pretty soon so I had to keep
it together hearts beat loud the role of
Frank Fisher and hearts beat loud was
just a dream come true of which I now
seem to have several which makes me feel
so lucky that it keeps me minding my
manners so that maybe I'll even get
another one I worked on a movie called
the hero which is a beautiful film this
guy named Brett Halley made I'll see you
in my dreams
starring Blythe Danner and then the hero
starring Sam Elliot and I was cast as
his pot dealing friend and I just
this guy's movies are wonderful he's
such a great filmmaker and he wrote his
next movie for me called hearts beat
loud and I was over the moon I mean it's
the first time I got to be a leading man
that was just like a normal guy like
like there were shots of me walking down
the street because the audience cares
about how my day is going I was like
what so I just walk and like feet emote
all right roll camera I'm sure that
means anything meanings meaning I want
it that way they want what what way
because it doesn't matter it's me I'm
sorry are you bringing up the Backstreet
Boys in reference to my lyrics all due
respect it's actually a pretty good song
oh come on
how did you get to be such a music snob
blythe danner plays my mom Ted Danson
Toni Collette I mean it's crazy but
Kiersey Clemons as my daughter is such a
knockout talent like when she started
singing well took a knee and said our
movie is going to be good it was so
gratifying to get to do that the first
day we met was in New York and it was I
don't know a week or two before we
started shooting we met to rehearse our
band to rehearse our music because
neither of us are like pro musicians I
wasn't even trying to like establish a
rapport it's just one like when your
co-star when you're a fellow actor
arrives whoever that may be you're like
hey hi and so you already know that
you're about to make this art project
together in which you love each other
and you go through like a journey
together you have some laughs you have
some tears then you meet her and you're
like hi
like we're about to get to dance
together we're gonna play some amazing
football together or whatever it is so
there's already a sort of a fondness a
camaraderie and then I just start
teasing her like messing with her like
one foundation of our relation
ship was me making fun of like my age
where I started texting her emojis I
started trying like way too hard with my
emoji game things like that where I was
like curiously I don't know if you're up
on what's fresh or fire with the kids
these days and you know and that would
really annoy her so we just immediately
had like a dad daughter rapport like dad
trying to be cool be like hey what's up
you do you do you like house music
because I'm down with that
devs I got a call that Alex Garland
wanted to meet with me for a TV series
and I was a very big fan of his I mean I
started crying a little bit when I got
that call because it was like Stanley
Kubrick or something where I was like it
was not in the realm of someone that
might call so that was it I was like
yeah whatever
count me in but then I got the scripts
and read them it was like said to my
wife honey I have a very good part in a
very exquisite 8 episode program and you
know everything just piled on from there
he turned out to be an absolute
dreamboat to work with and when someone
is a smart and talented as him and
they're dreamy then everybody else is
dreamy cuz everybody wants to work with
that and be around it so all the crew
and the heads of the departments all the
collaborators the producers the cast are
just one after the other they're
absolute astonishing thespian heroes and
so I I'm very grateful to be among them
when I get a job one of my one of the
things I relish the most is like okay
you got the job sometimes before even
before the deal closes I call the app
wherever the alex is and say okay what
whiskers can I have what weird hairdo
can I have can I shave my head in some
sort of way that will make my wife upset
I love to look
strange and unrecognizable so we talked
back and forth and ultimately Alex found
a picture of a guy and the incredibly
talented Nadia Stacy who did our hair
and makeup she won a BAFTA for the
favorite not a big deal she then took
the picture of this guy and like created
it on me
it was my beard but trimmed so she took
my crazy beard and made it different
crazy and made me look like a ginger and
then I had a shaved head so that was a
wig with like baldness on top what am I
actually doing here I'm not going to
tell you don't worry you're gonna figure
it out I come from Chicago theater and
and sometimes people hear that and they
mistake it for Chicago comedy and it's
two very separate things so I'm a street
theatre actor I'm not a trained comedy
performer I'm trained and like elocution
and sword fighting but when you do
theater you do whatever is on the season
and in any given theater season you
usually have a Shakespeare a Tracy Letts
drama a comedy so you sort of learn all
the tools I didn't aspire to work in
comedy or drama or any genre per se I
just hope to work on as good of writing
as possible and so I'm kind of having my
dream come true by getting to have a
variety of things I would I would would
not want to be known as a comedy star or
or you know only a tragedian I'd rather
be known as somewhat versatile who can
get the job done